my name is Lana yoganova and this event
is organized by the natural language
processing special interest group
given the interest that chat GPT has
generated in the last few months I'm
sure we are all impatient to get to the
contents of the stock today we have two
wonderful presenters to share with us
and address various aspects and
applications of chat GPT they are both
scientists in Dr Jeong Lewis a research
group at National Library of Medicine at
NIH
he will start us off he holds a PhD
degree in statistics and has a wide
range of experience in research and
Industry his current interest is in
using pre-trained language models for
various biomedical and clinical
applications including information
retrieval and information extraction
our second speaker is Dr Chao Jin who
interestingly before shifting his
research interest to computer science
and medical informatics he has obtained
a MD degree from the tsinghua University
in 2022 Dr Jean's current research
interests include deep learning natural
language processing information
retrieval and their applications in
biomedicine he has won the first biobank
disease AI Challenge and the track 2020
Precision medicine track
his work on evm Nets received the best
NLP paper award from the international
medical informatics Association in 2021
and his primary focus recently has been
to improve biomedical information access
with large language models
before I give this to Dr shubotian I
want to share with you that on the
videocast link there is a button that
says live feedback send live feedback so
you can use that button to send your
questions as we do expect that you will
have a lot of questions there will be a
10-15 minute time at the end of the talk
to answer these questions and we will
receive them and read them out to the
speakers and with that I'm happy to turn
this to Dr subotian
hi good afternoon everyone so thank you
so much for having us here and thank you
for joining this talk my name is and
today
um ciao Michael worker and I we together
are going to talk about chat CPT and
some other last language models and
their applications in that medicine
so chat zpt has been such a hot topics
in the last couple of months
um you know you acquired
um more than 100 million users in the
first two months and the Daily Business
to open ai's website it's more than 30
Millions
and if we search gpp on uh format we can
find articles containing chat GPT
um that were added to partner doubled
every month in the last five months
so today
um we're going to look into how large
language models like GPT
how they're created
um what capabilities they have and how
to unlock their powers
um as well as how to adapt these large
language models for our biomedical
applications
um before we dive into the details
um first let's look at what is a
language model
so a language model
is a model the compute either of these
two probabilities given a sequence of
words or tokens so the first one is the
result probability of the whole sequence
or the probability of the word condition
on its previous words or tokens
let's look at this example we have this
sentence
um
um we want to compute the probability
the probability of this or the words in
this sentence
um
we can compute
um this probability is equal to the
production of each word conditioned on
this previous words
so this is what
a link language models is
um
um language model has been an important
research area since 1950s
and the the first natural Network
language model was introduced in like
20 2001 and
um after the Transformer architecture
was introduced in
2017 it became the fundamental
architecture for most of the reason
language models
um um depending on the specific
architectures how his language models
use they can be grouped into three
categories
so here we can see
um because the Transformers include
um encoder and particular language
models can be built based on encoder
only or decoded only or include both the
encoder and decoder
language models include some models like
bird or is variants and decoder language
models include the
GPT families and some others
um we encoder and decoder language
models and include models like um tt5
of the band
and um since some researchers are
scaling up language models lead to
significance increase in their
capabilities
so in the last few years the size of
Linux models has been growing
um when we look at this stipulent type
of language models uh encoder only
language models and encoder decoder
language models are usually changed
using identity viewing always can say a
mask language model
or um spent corruption objectives
and the decoder language models are
usually shared in the causal language
model or Auto aggressive language model
and
um for encoded only on decoder
in called the decoder language models
that typically
change using large copies and they
fine-tuned uh using some Downstream plus
training data and then apply it to the
downstream task
but when changing gpt3 was introduced it
demonstrates
um increased generalizability so after
that change with large quarters of data
without fine tuning so these as leads up
in the recent development of the trend
uh to developing more of this decoder
only language models
and um we now
um like gpd3 it has demonstrated a
powerful capability in general like text
but sometimes they also produce some
toxic or biased
or harmful content so how can we align
these large language models to our human
preferred content
a group of researchers uh or young at
all they propose antique Collective
methods to fine-tune this last language
models to a human Facebook uh language
model so
um they use two steps to fighting these
English models so after I like lecture
gpd3 after the pretend with large and
scale covers
um
um they collect some problems
um from the API and then they uh as
human labelers to write some respect uh
content for this problem and then they
use this data to fine-tune the protein
language model and after they fighting
this model they collect you know for
each prompt uh this model can output
different contents so the correct with
different contents and then ask the
labelers to rate which one is better
than the others and then they use those
um ready data
put them together to find further
fighting the language model using a
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback and this is how the uh GPT and
the instruct GPT was created
and after on this model of iTunes they
become more Facebook for human beings
um
um without
language models lecture GPT are very
powerful but how can we unlock that
power
and this is how we can do yes
prompt entering engineering is the key
to unlock their power
so we can correct some useful prompt and
then fit them into the model and ask the
model to Output what we want generally
the contents we want it's a hey buddy
can you do something for me and then you
know you have a problem saying this is
what we want and then because this large
language models have very strong in
context learning and they're able to
output human like text so they can
output what you want
and and that many The Prompt engineering
techniques and here are some of them so
um some standard from engineering is
include this one sort learning well we
have a fast description and something we
want the model to do so we use this as a
prompt and fit into the model and that's
the model to Output what we want or we
can include some examples for the model
to learn through the income learning
ability so if we have one example this
is we can call it this is one shot
learning and we also include several
examples as a few shortly and input them
to the model to have our output and for
some
um complex
[Music]
for the model to
generate the correct answer so in this
case a group of researchers uh way at
all they propose an effective way called
Chain of Thought from engineering so
um in this case in this example if we
just input the question and then have
just input the answer is 11 here the
model and I asked the model to answer
this question
usually they will give you a lot answer
but if we ask the model I say let's
recently step by step and input these
written steps include in this Louisiana
steps in the front and input into the
model and the model will also generate
the media steps and then the right the
correct answer
so we know
um last language models like GPT are
very powerful but how can we adapt them
for our biomedical applications
um there are many uh skills or many
strategies we can use but these are the
main strategies now you can use any one
of them or a combination of some of them
to you know adapt the models to for our
biomedical application and we can
change the whole model from scratch like
these models the kitchen number gpp or
we can initiate a model from the food
chain uh General language model and then
further pre-train them with uh uh about
my little cop is how we can exactly use
the model and then do some task specific
functioning to adapt them to a specific
task and for some large language models
is pretty difficult or very expensive to
pretend them or for the pretending in
this case now the
um the easiest way is to use from
engineering to teach the model to
generally what we like or we can do some
um use some soft ground technique to
fine tune the plant or you know if you
want to adapt the whole model to The
Domain we can you know create some data
and then fine tune the model so this
technique is a more expensive than these
two and
um this will update the whole model's
Planet I make it more better for adapt
to the in domain tasks industrial
um is less expensive but you will need
to find the right one so yeah this is
how we how we can adapt the last
language models for our application uh
next child will cover several
applications of GPT and last language
models so I just take from here uh thank
you both for your wonderful introduction
on the largest models and for my part I
will cover uh three applications that
are related to biomedical information
needs so first question what are
biomedical information needs well as
general public we might have a lot of
questions about biomedicine for example
I might ask so I got a flu shot this is
a legit format of confirmation need
because we might want to know the
benefits or uh the side effects of a flu
shot and it's rather important to
precisely answer this need
and sometimes we are patients and we
might have some symptoms for example
women have a fever and a headache and
the women I want to know what shall we
do uh can we just do some self-diagnosis
and buy some OTC drug or shall we
directly go to the doctor's office in
the emergency departments
so uh for doctors clinicians they might
want to know the up-to-date guidelines
to treat specific patients with some
symptoms and past medical histories and
we also have information needs from
researchers scientists about the
specific growing Pathways mechanisms of
diseases and the drug targets and also
from the biomedical curators who are
basically maintaining all these
biomedical databases and they want to
know the new findings to update the for
example Gene entries in the database
as you can see there are various
biomedical information needs and there's
vitally important to serve all these
information needs and this brings us to
our first application today which is the
question answering past or QA in short
because just as we discussed information
needs are naturally expressed by
questions in natural language so the
process of answering questions is a
process of serving information needs and
this is question answering this task has
been extensively studied in both General
domain and biomedical NLP and this is a
hard task because it requires the model
to have several capabilities to perform
well
so first the model needs to be
knowledgeable which means that the model
should know something about biomedicine
for example a patient might come with a
list of symptoms sometimes ABCDE and the
model needs to know what diseases uh are
associated with each other and this this
is sometimes relationship is just one
aspect of the biomical knowledge that
the model should possess to perform well
on this task and second the model should
do reasoning well which means that the
model should understand the context of
the question the context of the
information needs
well uh for example theory is very
knowledgeable but it often fails because
it cannot understand your question and
this is especially true in biomedicine
because for example patients they might
come with a long question with a lot of
non-standard terminologies for example a
patient might say Hey doctor I'm not
feeling well and I'll start it yesterday
when I was eating with my daughter and
blah blah blah is a long story and after
all there's a question and it's vitally
important to understand the whole story
the whole progression of the disease you
precisely to precisely answer the
question
and uh besides knowledge and reasoning
the model should also align with human
values so what is alignment uh which in
the case of biomedicine for example
patients might ask very basic questions
for example what does this blood glucose
mean and as a knowledgeable AI model and
can do perfect reasoning the model
cannot say that why do you ask this uh
basic naive question or your questions
too naive this is not helpful and this
actually does harm to the patient
so instead the model should say that
well blood glucose is a measure of sugar
in your blood so in this case the model
is really helpful and along with human
values
and the performance of NLP model is
measured by our standardized data sets
and if I only have time to introduce one
data set for uh biometrical questions
and that is that would be the math QA
U.S Emily data sets this is perhaps the
most widely used biomedical data set for
evaluating large engine models and as
you can tell from the name it's a U.S
Emily stands for the United States
medical license examination so
examination data set where for each
instance you have a question that's the
description of the patients and you are
also given 45 possible choices like a b
say d e and your task is choose the
right choice from all the possible
choices and after you have the model
prediction you compare it with the grand
choose answer and get the accuracy score
and that is the performance of the model
and let me show you a concrete example
from the from the US Emily data set so
this is a question and the question is
basically description of patience 27
year old HIV positive female give birth
to your baby girl and the long context
then the questions which of the
following essays should the hospital use
to detect something and for choices uh
Eliza If you have an antibody and p7000
so
you should input the entire question uh
as well as the four choices the whole
thing to a larger model and besides it
you also need to input this famous chain
of dot instruction let's think step by
step to the live stream model because if
you do not input this sentence the model
will directly say well the answer is B
well that kind of answer has a higher
Arrow risk but if you input this
instruction the model instead will
reason from the very beginning from like
the first principles and your long
reasoning chain because something is in
something and so the answer is something
and that has a higher success rates
so and as you can tell from the question
there are two requirements to answer
this correctly first knowledge uh which
means that model needs to know what
Eliza is what HIV is and what these are
is so on so forth and the second model
needs to do reasoning because you know
it's a long question even for me I spent
some time to comprehend what's the
information you need in this question so
knowledge and reasoning
and uh this is example of the tax
generated by large models so large
length models their core capabilities to
generate Things based on something and
in this case uh before the orange bar
you input everything to a logical model
and after this orange bar everything is
generated by the large model and as you
can see the first word is about how HIV
infection works and the virus enters the
body and begins to replicate in cells so
it's like really listening from the
first principles and the step-by-step uh
it's a long resonation and after all the
model says therefore the answer is to
say which is the correct answer the
model does well on this question well
that's just one question so what's the
performance of our questions in the test
set
before we talk about that another good
thing about math query data set is that
is also a standardized task for humans
so that we have human scores uh we have
two scores the human passing score which
is uh 60 out of 100 and this typically
for example a medical student would have
a score and we also have the human
exercise core uh which is like 87 and uh
from for example an experienced doctor
and we can cast what's the best model's
performance but the model is not a large
ranking model that's before the error of
margin model what you can tell from the
uh Arrangements of These Bars because
this is the leftmost bar so it should
have the lowest performance and actually
the performance of this model uh is 47
but shipped by a model called dragon by
Stanford and this paper was published in
Europe 22. so this is a really a great
model beautifully designed the state of
the art but you only had 47 scores way
below the human passing score
and then we enter the arrow of Largent
models and the first model is GPT 3.5
this is basically 2gbt and the score of
it is just slightly above 60 60.2 or
something but it already created a lot
of news pipelines basically saying that
jgp passes the UI assembly test and this
is really hugely given that the previous
gas model is only 47 you bypass all the
50s directly going to 60s so hugely for
the first largest model
and then we have the mattapon model so
Palm is Google's Pathways language model
it's Google's counterpart for uh gpt3
and metapom is medical version of pound
so the performance of mad Palm is like
67 something and uh it's definitely an
improvements over gp3 but it's still in
the 60s
and then we have gp4 which is a much
more capable version of gbt by open Ai
and so its performance is like 82
something and you can say it's a huge
leap from Mad pump to gp4 because you
bypass all 70s directly going to 80s
which is the same level as a human
expert and after gpd4 we have the
marathon 2 so pump 2 is Google's
counterpart for gpt4 and mad pump 2 is a
medical version of pump 2 and it has
further improvements like performance
going to 85 so now the performance is
really close to the human expert score
of 87 and I'm pretty sure that in the
near future uh large entry models will
definitely surpass the human expert
sport because everything from the first
logic model to the current bus it
happens within half a year and given
that is from the human person score
through the human expert score takes
tens of years for humans since just half
a year for logging models so it's huge
Improvement
and let's go to our second application
today which is the summarization task so
unlike questions where you give a
question to large model and directly
gets an answer for summarization you not
only need a question but you also need
to give the model several articles or
documents uh for the model and the model
will summarize the provided articles the
documents to answer your question
and as you can imagine there are
multiple scenarios information where
summarization works for example you can
use Largent models to summarize medical
evidence basically provide this
randomized control articles uh one of
them or a collection of them to a larger
model and then large engine model will
summarize uh this rcts it's basically
automatic evidence synthesis it's like
they are providing a draft of systematic
reviews for you and that's really
helpful
and some people also argue that jgp
might be the future of discharge
summaries because this discharge
summaries are basically summarization of
all previous clinical notes
and you can also apply uh this large
enough models to Radiology reports you
can use it to combine the predictions of
different image models and generate a
single report and based on this report
you can interact with patients answer
patient's question for example patients
might ask what's my diagnosis what's the
prognosis and what medicine should I
take
so there are many scenarios where
summarization helps
we always talk about how large models
can uh do question answering can do
summarization however they still cannot
serve some information as well for
example if I ask this question to jgbt
please list basically symptoms of long
covet and also ask it to cite those
article titles and their PM IDs and here
is the response from LGBT and as you can
see this whole response is looking very
plausible because the list of symptoms
and for example fatigue muscle weakness
and you also have the article source
article titles uh and also I have the
pmibs that are eight digits they look
really real even for me but
if you carefully verify everything in
the response you will find that uh
basically most of the article titles are
totally fabricated and all the pmis they
exist but uh their articles are not
relevant from not relevant to the latest
symptoms which means that large links
models basically make up everything in
the response and this is a huge issue
and this is this issue is known as the
hallucination issue in the literature
and this indicates that you cannot
directly use a large model as a search
engine
the good news is that there are multiple
ways that we can tackle the
hallucination issue and the most obvious
way is called retrieval augmentation so
uh in this virtual augmentation we are
basically combining a large model and a
search engine well you can think of the
case of the new being and I will give
you an example of cgp with the web
browsing plugin where I basically asked
this question so which movie won't Oscar
award this year
so as you may know that chip GPT the
training data is before 20 2021 so this
is now in the training data of kgpt but
if you allow jtp to search the web using
a search engine like Google or Bing you
can search your question and get the
retrieval list of relevant web pages
from that search engine for example list
of Articles a list of news and uh jgp
can also read all the text in that news
and based on the text answer question
it's like they are provided with
relevant documents to your question and
this task suddenly becomes a
summarization task which large enough
models do pretty well extremely well
and for this question uh security waste
the web browsing plugin answers my
question correctly with this reading
content feature and the size the right
uh article that is a news from say um
so we can do
the same ritual augmentation for the
previous previous example of
non-coverage symptoms basically we
actually proposed a Trilogy of retrieval
summarization and verification for
literature search with the help of
larger models and the first step is
retrieval so it's super easy you just
provide relevant articles of
long-covered symptoms
you just need to collect their titles
their abstracts and these articles you
can find them through Palmetto any other
search engine and this is the first
retrieval step
and the second step is summarization
basically input your question and all
relevant documents to jdbt and then cgpt
will summarize these documents to answer
your question and in this case jgp does
a much better job compared to the
previous example of
fabrication uh it provides a list of
symptoms extracted from the provided
list and all these pmids are also chosen
from the provider list and they are
relevant to the symptoms
so it does a much better job but you
still need a third step that is
verification because uh if you carefully
verify them there are still some issues
for example some some combination can be
improved and some listed items are not
actually symptoms so you still need to
verify the output before you can
actually use it but I would say these
are not fatal arrows like fabrication
and as models improve I think they will
make less this kind of arrows but
overall we think the trilogy of
retrieval summarization and
verifications the future of biomedical
literature search with the help of large
language models
well
even with retrieval augmentation you
still cannot answer some questions for
example this question what is the gene
associated with this need this one I
asked it to ggp with web browsing uh
plugin tgp says that it seems that
there's limited or no public information
available for this specific speaker
well why because surprisingly uh all
these commercial search engines like
Google or being they just do not index
the specialized databases maintained by
for example ncbi in this case the DB
snip is not indexed by the search engine
so you do not find anything from the web
what you will need to do is you need to
use the specific database in this case
dbsnip and you need to find the snap
page in that database and you need to
check out the gene name of the snip and
get answer
rc23 that's the gene you are looking for
well this might be obvious to you but
for a lot of beginners for a lot of
laypersons they don't even know that
this database exists and uh and as you
can imagine there are hundreds of
thousands of biomedical databases in the
world together on the web and what if we
can teach large models to use all this
biomedical databases and the given users
question the model automatically tells
which database you use and how to use
the database and provide the answer to
users question and for this we propose a
two augmented large link model called
Gene GPT where we are basically teaching
large length models to use ncbi web apis
and with the ncpr web apis you can
access all the biomedical databases
maintained by ncbi for example DB snip
I'm at clean bar omin so and so forth
and you can also use all this for
informatics tools offered by ncbi like
the famous plus 2 for sequence alignment
and let me show you a concrete example
so for this question what is the
function of the gene associated with
this mean this one uh let's let's
decompose the question to sub questions
and solve them step by step so this is a
harder question than the previous one
because it's a model of questions if you
first need to get a gene name and then
you need to get a function and this is
the output of Gene GPT the first
decomposes the question to two sub
questions and First Step question is
which Gene is this name associative ways
and GPT knows that for this question it
needs to consult with it needs to use
the database tool and it generates a URL
which we call the web API request and
basically if you click this URL you'll
get the raw outputs of everything on the
snip information page and we just help
execute this API call and print the raw
information to the model context and the
last Gene GPD continue generation based
based on the apical results and the gene
GPT gets the correct answer which lrc23
and it then asks a second sub question
and cause another API and finally gets
the right answer so this shows that
besides a search engine you can also
augment large links models with domain
specific tools like database utilities
and to provide improved Excel to
biomedical information for the users
and uh that's the three applications I
talk about uh first is question
answering uh where large models achieve
state-of-the-art performance close to
human experts and the second is
summarization where you can find
multiple scenarios in biomedicine that
is useful and the third is information
retrieval although you cannot use
license models as a search engine uh you
can combine large info models with the
search engine like in the case of new
bin and GPD browsing feature for
retrieval augmentation and you can also
combine license models with domain
specific tools like in the case of ggbt
and qgpt plugins for improved access to
biomatic information and that's for my
part thanks okay that's welcome super
back for more introduction of the
applications
thanks out
um yes
um I will continue to talk some other
applications let me share my screen
so um the next one I'm going to talk
about is um about information
instruction so information instruction
um it's a task to extract some
um biomedical Concepts and then
relations from the from some medical
text so this is a very important
application which can be used to support
evacuation for biomedical knowledge
discovery
um traditionally this task was
formulated as a token classification
class or sequence labeling tasks which
we predict each token into
um a concept or not and we after we do
that we you know we extract some
representation of a pair of Concepts and
then predict them into a relationship
um and traditionally they um this tasks
used
is encode on me
um language models for this application
but some researchers also is brought to
use some decoder language models for
this application but from here we can
see some the performance of encoder
language models is much better than the
performance of because the only language
models
um this is for
Nam entity recognition
that's to identify the medical Concepts
from the text
and this is lesson for a relation
instruction
um
most of the Epic most of the language
models used for relation instruction are
encode the only language models and yeah
there's some research on using uh
something called the language models
well this application but still they are
still
underperformed compared to the decoder
language models
um
I think the
why in this encoder language models are
doing worse than the decoder ones
probably because
um this language model is uh this
decoder language model we usually
formulate the task as an text generation
task so we input the whole text into the
model and ask the models to deploy
output the uh this biomedical Concepts
and that relationship and
um there are some problems that
sometimes they will just rephrase the
output
Concepts or they will just rely on the
relationship between these Concepts so
uh given some traditional evaluation
metrics like precision and we call
probably that's what the region uh for
this language models to underperform the
important language models
some
appropriate front
all five a better way to apply this
decoder language models like GPT
probably we will be able to you know to
increase their performance compatible at
least to the encoder language models
um in the other application is medical
vision and language models on this
application
can be used to for you know for this uh
medical image classification or for a
radiology report generation
um usually
these models will include an image
encoder and text encoder and then
um the trend on some image and test pass
using a contrastive loss learning
techniques
and
um several models have been debated and
these models are you know they because
the the clips the conscious learning it
means changing a language and image for
training model
um demonstrate very successful for some
image and text application so
um that
um several models based on these clips
learning techniques have been developed
um on this model it usually we use a
Visa model like on a vision a
Transformer model or a wrestling model
and they use both some encoder or
decoder links models as a language model
to encode the test and these models have
been shown to perform pretty well
um but as we can see some last language
models lecture GPT haven't been
dishboard for this application but given
the you know this various strong text
generation capability of transability or
some other language models who believe
um you know if we can find a right way
to use them together with some region
models they should be able to
medical region and language models
um the last couple of applications uh
mostly natural language processing
related but how long last language
models like gpp can not only use for
those applications that can be used for
some other applications like medical
education or scientific research as well
um here we will specifically talk about
medical education so
um you know we know these large language
models lecture GPT that pretend with
large
scale Text data and they encode a lot of
knowledge in the model so they can serve
at least as a knowledge base to provide
some insights or
um first for some students to ask them
questions and then they can provide some
discrimination
um uh some models lecture GDP they also
serve very strong conversational
interaction ability so you know if we
can use these models
um to develop a more Interactive
Learning way or learning environment
they will benefit
these medical students too but uh you
know just not use these models for
medical education
um they also have some of the cons you
know as challenges on this experience
they they can be um they can hallucinate
so they they may produce some
counterfectual or long information of
the results uh output from these models
may not be reliable or you know uh
although they encode a lot of blank uh
knowledge including some uh clinical
medical knowledge in the model
um they're not able to capture the full
complexity of this knowledge all the few
decisions making process for some
clinical application
so these are all the applications we we
talk in um in this talk in the
biological document now although these
language models like Trend GPT and
they're very powerful but they still
have their limitations and impose some
risk you know to train this model is
very expensive you know they can produce
some wrong information they can impose
accepting risk but uh you know the most
relevant to about medical clinical
applications We Believe are the buyers
you know inherited by these models
um
this bias can be
um can be gender biased can be raised by
us you know some losers already find
some language models have some NK uh
Muslim buyers you know we know in some
uh technical applications some some
groups you know these different
genders or races may be biased
so when we use the
um contest to check the model they will
make the model bus too and the harm of
this buyers can include you know that
they can produce some disparity of
service qualities or some
um discriminations towards some certain
groups
um ciao already talked about
um the hallucination uh Lewis and this
is even not critical for last language
models because with the increased
capability they're able to produce more
believable are convincible content so
you know when we're using these language
models we need to be
um some
especially a higher
causes and privacy yeah this is and also
true you know in the the data used to
check the model may include some
individual personal information some
researchers already required they can
identify some individual information
from distinguished models and you know
when this blank model used for some
clinical application they have access to
some pensions uh personal data so this
could impose some Lewis to individuals
and when we use
gdpp for some research and use them to
help for manuscript writing and they
also cause some authorship excuse some
journals already bench listing or gpp I
think also and um this is some risk and
limitations with we believe we need to
take caution when we use
2gbt or other language models where
application
and yeah
although these models have the
limitations and risks but we believe if
we can use this models properly
um we should be confident to have a
vision that we can pick up some kind of
General Road lead more AI models or
applications when we're looking forward
yeah and uh this is the work uh about a
group
and we'd like to thank all our group
members
um I'm not going to read their names one
by one uh we thank them for their
contributions and helps and we think
especially Dr Luke for his advice and
supervision
and this is what we talk in this uh this
talk and we're ready to take questions
questions
thank you so much sugar and ciao this is
a really hot topic because I have
received dozens of questions and so if
uh let's I will start asking the
questions in the order they have
received we apologize we won't be able
to get all the questions but I may take
a liberty to promise uh that we will try
to get your questions by email if we
don't get to them in the in the live
video presentation today and also so
some people are joining us from zoom and
most people are joining us from
videocast as I said from videocast there
is a button to click to send your email
question if you are joining us from Zoom
please do not unmute yourself rather
send your question to the email that
that has been provided so with that I
will start with the questions so I have
a few questions that are in the category
of Gene Gene a GPT ciao so
GPT and the question is uh will it be
publicly available are you planning on
deploying it as a plugin and how can
people engage with that application
okay so uh thanks for your interest and
the great questions the first questions
would be publicly available downstairs
yes we will release the code and you can
replicate all everything on GitHub and
the second uh Railway uh like write a
plugin for change APK or make it the
Deployable uh it's uh we are not quite
sure because if we want to do that we
might need to call Open Eyes API
ourselves and uh that model has been has
been deprecated so and that also costs a
lot of money so we are considering that
but we are not sure
and was a third question third question
is
uh so that that was about Gene GPT so we
will be able to provide a way for people
to use that tool correct yeah yeah yeah
yes yeah wonderful so we will as as soon
as that's available we can send that
link through our natural language
processing special interest group
listserved so please please be on the
lookout another group of questions is
about the controversial answers or
questions that have conflicting answers
so people are wondering how is chat GPT
um
you know defining how to answer it so
uh do they present an average answer or
is is the system able to recognize
differences in understanding
can can you address that the questions
that can have controversial answers or
conflicting answers what is your you
know take on that
uh so what do you want to answer this
question
um yeah sure I you know I can I can
provide some comments
um you know these language models have
changed on very large scale of text
so they learn how to produce their
output from what they learn you know on
this text Data
um
it's very difficult to say you know if
they understand or not you know somehow
yes you know we we use dictator to train
the model and the model was learning in
the
in a kind of
it's a it's kind of you know when we
converge the data this text Data into
numeric data and then do the computation
somehow they learn something but it's
very difficult to
you know to verify if they really learn
or not so
um they they're able to they learn to
produce and we just talk about the
language models so they've learned to
produce
um a text
um the probability of producing some
text from what they learn so it may
produce
um you know different different texts
from the model yeah so this this uh
contest may be conflict
a child maybe you can comment more
also from my understanding is that if
there is conflicting or contradicting
evidence especially in medical
literature for example why the Melatonin
is good for your house let's say there
are little articles things good the
Articles thing is bad and uh
theoretically if you train your language
models well on all these articles
everything will be in the memory of the
large large model and uh but the answer
actually depends on your question so if
you ask this question differently you'll
get different answers and the uh uh E5
if I'm going to do that I will try to
ask questions in various uh diverse ways
to get uh many many answers many tablets
answers and basically and check their
average and get the results also called
like self-consistency prompting
so everything is in the memory it just
depends on your question
thank you thank you for that explanation
um I have another question which says it
is well known that GPT and large
language model Technologies are prone to
hallucination responses and I know we
addressed that a little bit so what
steps are being taken to ensure that
trustworthy information is being
delivered
uh well so another great question I
think they ensure this uh basically uh
generally speaking safety and the
privacy and this kind of issue first in
the project is that they filter all this
uh bad sources like uh uh really bad
messages on Twitter it just filter all
this information so their training site
is kind of clean and this is the first
step training and then they will do
what's called a reinforcement learning
with human feedback so they are
basically teaching lodging models how to
respond the question properly and uh
that's uh taught by human labelers and
that's the second step of controlling
that and uh there I mean there can be uh
high level layers built upon this uh uh
Largent models like you can have a model
detecting whether model of whether a
large model outputs something bad and
you can just the design not to show that
like in the case of new being but there
are many ways and the people are
actually addressing this very seriously
okay one one question that is more uh on
a general uh that's more of a general
question and I just want to say that
it's three o'clock now so we officially
are done with the hour but our av team
has allowed us to extend this for
another few minutes so if sugar and Chao
you are available for the few more
minutes maybe you can cover a couple
more questions okay so how how do you
guys think this chat GPT will change the
general landscape for example young
people who are going to school now who
are starting their college
and they are confused to in in terms of
how will GPD influence careers you know
will that career be uh in demand in the
next five or ten years do you have any
idea what what is your vision of the
future let's say in five ten years which
careers or how can it affect the choice
of career for a young generation
first uh
uh do you want to answer this super
um yeah I can I can take it and maybe
you can have more comments um I
I would say you know if we look at
um like GPT you know they're very
powerful to serve as a knowledge base
so
um if
um you're looking for a job it's more
like supportive job
probably you will have a large impact
and if you
your job is more
decisive so you know you you need to
verify all the information and then make
a decision on that
probably will have a less impact
and also we can we can see oh we already
saw
GPT already bring many jobs of magnetic
month of product engineers
so you know how do you
inspired on how to dig the knowledge
from these language models also requires
some skills so I think this this is this
is what I see
so so your take on it is that some some
things will disappear but other careers
will will open up other opportunities
will come up yes okay okay great thank
you for for your question uh ciao so if
chat GPT is giving you a summary of long
coveted symptoms
and the PMI these titles are wrong then
where are those symptoms coming from
uh well
that's a good question so uh I would say
the large models if we look at from the
first principles they are trained to
predict the next token in all the
training materials so it's like it has a
classic memory and uh it's just based on
all previous taxes January the next
token that's most possible in the
training Corpus and I would say if you
frame a question like that uh uh the
tags generated by enlargement model are
most likely to appear in the for example
apartment articles but that doesn't mean
that there are two that it just means
that they are they have higher
probabilities they are more fluent for
example so and because you input long
covet and maybe the model says covet and
it's just the output some words
associated with covet
so it's it's definitely not
that precise
correct correct okay so maybe we can
take a couple more questions and
conclude with that but one question we
have a bunch of questions that are on
privacy
clearly as we know like hallucinations
and privacy are one of the most issues
with Ted GPT so this creates a lot of
interest so how can we ensure privacy
and security of sensitive patient
biomedical information while using chat
GPT and and this is quite a general
question so I guess we have to speak
about certain uses of chantipity how do
you use it but can you say anything
towards that so how can we ensure
privacy and security of sensitive
patient information
yeah I um I can provide some comments on
on here
um
you know privacy is also um uh that many
research have been done on on this issue
so you know when we're trying to use
clinical data at least mathematical data
a lot of research have been done to deep
identification you know on the
identification of this information so
um you know we at the beginning when we
have this data we uh develop some
language models to identify this
personalized video information and then
just remove them or replace them with
some different data or have some
script like like the the date
the age which has you know shipped to a
certain number so
um
I don't think is
possible to totally you know resolve
this problem but
um
with these techniques to the
identification and
um and you know with Kev with some care
when we're using these models uh it
should be better
okay thank you thank you and I have one
more question that is related to Gene
GPT so it's with ncbi databases there's
less cohesive text for llm algorithms to
learn from the scientific databases are
disjointed with lots of symbols numbers
table format Etc how can models like
child GPT systems learn from scientific
databases effectively is llm the best
choice or maybe other models can be
edited well that's a excellent question
and uh we actually did a lot of chrome
engineering to make Gene GPD possible
for example we not just input the user's
question engine GPT will also input a
lot of in-context examplers to Gene GPS
like we are showing tntpd how to respond
to different kinds of biomedical
questions and how we can use the ncbi
tools in the context basically we
provide all these examples in the input
to the large larger model and in-depth
process we are teaching the largest
model to use in CBI web apis but if we
do not input all these examples they
might fail as the as you might expect
thank you very much ciao so
um I think it's time to wrap up our
meeting uh thank you audience thank you
everybody for joining us thank you Shiva
and ciao for giving this very exciting
talk and for taking all these questions
um we will try to get back to as many
questions as we can please email email
us your questions you can continue
emailing and uh
um see you at the next meeting goodbye
everybody
goodbye all right thanks